[Música]
hace
hace más de 30 años que me dedico a los
temas ambientales soy biólogo soy
periodista
si el conductor del único programa de
ecología que hay en la televisión
abierta de la argentina
estuve en la expo 92 del río de janeiro
hace muchísimo tiempo
allí se consagró al desarrollo
sustentable como la panacea que habría
de resolver todos los problemas
ambientales
problemas ambientales que tres décadas
más tarde coincidirán conmigo están
empeorados en todos sus indicadores
en aquel momento el diagnóstico común
era que el obstáculo que había que
sortear para efectivamente resolver los
problemas ambientales era la falta de
conciencia
todavía hoy se dice eso a pesar de la
pueblada de gualeguaychú a pesar de las
mujeres de famatina que le pusieron el
pecho a la barrick a pesar del
plebiscito de esquel que rechazó
abrumadoramente la minería a cielo
abierto a pesar de las mujeres y madres
del barrio ituzaingó anexo aquí en
córdoba que disimulaban con pañuelos las
calvicies derivadas de los tumores que
le habían provocado las fumigaciones
a pesar
de que nos piden que separemos la basura
en nuestras casas y separamos la basura
de nuestras casas en un país que tiene
3000 basurales a cielo abierto
de todos esos males contaminación
fumigación en minería basura cambio
climático somos responsables simplemente
porque no tenemos la conciencia
individual suficiente
el mundo funciona con una definición de
progreso que atrasa
hace 50 años mayor cantidad de basura
generada era sinónimo de crecimiento
mayor cantidad de pesticidas o
fertilizantes echados sobre los campos
era indicativo de productividad todavía
hoy
se mide el progreso en toneladas de
hormigón
y se considera progreso agarrar una
montaña y voltearla para separar el oro
con cianuro o se considera progreso
cortar en cuatro el único río glaciar yo
de la patagonia que la atraviesa de
oeste a este y poner en riesgo a una
especie en peligro de extinción para
construir dos represas hidroeléctricas
el papá francisco dedicó su primera
encíclica al medio ambiente law datos y
como uno esperaría de una creencia
religiosa cualquiera sea
lo que una guarda es una convocatoria al
compromiso individual a la solidaridad a
la bondad
sin embargo dijo el papá no basta
conciliar en un término medio el cuidado
de la naturaleza con la renta financiera
o la preservación del ambiente con el
progreso en este tema el medio ambiente
dijo el papá
los términos medios son apenas una
pequeña demora en el derrumbe se trata
subrayó de redefinir el progreso
las soluciones que se nos han presentado
hasta el día de hoy mantienen intacta
esa definición arcaica de progreso y nos
responsabilizan a nosotros
a nosotros como sinónimo de la humanidad
pero quién es ese nosotros somos todos
son algunos ese nosotros no es un actor
o un sujeto político social es una
abstracción
es como cuando frente a un determinado
problema se dice los responsables somos
todos
eso es lo mismo que no querer saber
quién es el verdadero responsable o lo
que es peor mantener ocultos a los
verdaderos responsables
entonces para mantener vigente un
sistema de exacción de los recursos
naturales que disfrazado de progreso nos
ha traído hasta el marasmo actual el
sistema diseñó al nuevo hombre verde
el hombre verde es sustentable
es amigable con el ambiente es parte del
progreso y es respetuoso con la
naturaleza y carga sobre sus espaldas
con la noble tarea de salvar a la tierra
para lo cual tiene que cumplir
deberes ecológicos que se le piden o se
le exigen aún cuando su aporte no
resulte significativo a la hora de
cambiar las cosas sin embargo el nuevo
hombre verde separa la basura
no malgasta el agua
apaga las luces que no se utilizan va
con la bolsita de tela al supermercado
consume productos orgánicos y mientras
tanto en todos y cada uno de los
rincones del planeta quienes lo
responsabilizan por la catástrofe
ecológica con el cambio climático como
un horizonte apocalíptico exprimen los
recursos naturales hasta agotarlos y en
busca de mayor concentración y
acumulación de riqueza bienes y poder el
neoliberalismo a través de sus estados y
sus corporaciones
apela a su voluntarismo y a su
sentimiento de culpa les doy un dato
100 empresas 100 no más con nombre y
apellido son responsables en todo el
planeta del 71 por ciento de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
que se acumulan en la atmósfera entonces
el nuevo hombre verde es una síntesis
maliciosa de nosotros como sinónimo de
la humanidad porque acaso es ese
nosotros capaz de erradicar los
basurales a cielo abierto o imponer las
energías renovables o frenar esa
tendencia creciente de emisiones de
dióxido de carbono antes de que el
planeta llegue a su punto de no retorno
a quién va dirigida esa apelación
el problema
es que la sociedad es una construcción
colectiva
y las construcciones colectivas los
comportamientos y las conductas de las
construcciones colectivas se modifican a
través de las políticas públicas y las
políticas públicas que son el umbral más
alto de la conciencia para poder
transformar positivamente la relación
entre la sociedad y la naturaleza
debieran respetar las cuatro leyes de la
ecología de barrica o manera primera ley
de la ecología de barrick cómo poner
todo está conectado con todo lo demás a
un estímulo le corresponde un efecto
si se promueve una política productiva
que consiste en tapizar el 70% de la
superficie cultivable de un país con una
sola especie la soja transgénica por
acción o por omisión se está diseñando
un escenario ambiental futuro según la
ley de la ecología de barrick componer
la naturaleza es más sabia lo que la
naturaleza no inventó no fue porque no
se le ocurrió
sino porque lo testeo y no le dio
positivo a la relación costo/beneficio
la naturaleza no inventó el monocultivo
sencillamente porque no es sustentable
tercera ley de la ecología de barrio y
como nerd
en la naturaleza no existe el tenedor
libre no hay posibilidades de ir a
servirse como si los recursos fuesen
ilimitados porque los recursos son
finitos y porque en la naturaleza los
ecosistemas tienden a la complejidad no
al crecimiento volumétrico cuarta ley de
la ecología de barrio como nerd todo va
a parar a alguna parte y en la
naturaleza no hay afuera no existe la
posible de sacar la basura en la
naturaleza porque la naturaleza funciona
con ciclos de materia y de energía el
residuo es un concepto social
entonces el nuevo hombre verde no es un
superhéroe pero sí es una condición
necesaria que se va a volver suficiente
si entendemos que es parte de un todo
podemos hacer algo en el medio sí claro
seguir con esas tareas
pero entender que somos parte de una
construcción colectiva y que como tales
tenemos que exigir políticas públicas
con proyectos planes metas y evaluación
de la calidad ambiental hay una cosa hay
que hacerlo rápido porque sólo nos queda
medio ambiente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah